今日から一週間
ちょっとコチラのスマホケースで
生活してみようと思います。
そしてこちら
気になる値段はなんと！
38万円！！！！！
ｽﾞｰﾁｬｯｽﾞｰﾁｬｯ
木魚っぽいヤツ♪
え、スマホケースを
コチラの巨大なスマホケースに変えて
生活しますと言って
ま、一応
1週間、巨大なスマホケースで
生活してみたんですけども
（はじめ無言）
（すごい顔）
ﾖﾀﾞﾚ（ｱｯﾔﾍﾞ ｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞ）
まっちょっとまあ
使用感といいますか
なかなかこのサイズの
スマホケースを使ってみて
どう思ったか
何を感じたか
ま、ちょっと1週間だけなんですけども
コレを使ってみて色々と
思ったことがあったので
ほんとに結構いろんなこと思ったので
ま、実際に役に立つこともあれば
役に立たないこともあったので
ちょっと色々
見ていこうと思います。
ではどうぞ！！！
♪
行かなきゃ！
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯ
ﾌｧｯｯ
スマホがないｯｯｯ！
ﾃﾝﾃﾝﾃﾝﾃﾚﾝﾃﾚﾝ(?)
（スマホを探すはじめ）
（スマホを見つけたはじめ）
あった～
いってきまーす
あっ、いっった
ﾏｸﾄﾞｩﾅﾙﾄﾞｩ
ﾏｸﾄﾞｩﾅﾙﾄﾞｩ ﾌｸﾛ ﾅｹﾞﾙ
ﾌﾙｩﾘｨ
ﾁｷﾝｸﾘｽﾌﾟ(?)
おつかれさまでーす
あっあっ
（ＢＧＭと雨音）
（ドアを開けるはじめ）
うわぁ雨やんけ　くっそ
あ、
（ＬＩＮＥ着信音）
もしもし？
うん
あぁうん
おっけーい
あ～っ
今日の動画なにすっかな～
はっ
はっ、どんっ、すぱんすぱんすぱん
ジィィィ
っっっほ
はい、というわけで
いかがだったでしょうか
ま、ほんとに
大きな利点といえば
失くしてもすぐ見つかるっていうところ、、
のみです。
ま、基本的に大きいし邪魔だし
重いし、痛いし、目立つし
ま、あんまり良いところがなかった
スマホケースでした。。。
二度と使わねえ☆
ｽﾞｰﾁｬｯｽﾞｰﾁｬｯｽﾞｰﾁｬｯｽﾞｰﾁｬｯ
ﾃｰｰｰﾃﾚﾚﾚｰﾚｰｰｰ
ﾃﾚﾚﾚｰｰｰﾃﾚﾚﾚｰﾚｰｰ
ﾚﾚﾚﾚｰｰ
(初字幕でした有難う御座いました！)
おもっ、、
これ持ち歩くの頭おかしいよ
えへっ